I welcome this president on behalf of our group.
A lot of
costs are paid, we are still paying
the last thing in Sweden and
they said we wanted 30 terrorists and they
said we
will not give you terrorists You will not give us terrorists but you will ask us to join NATO
They wanted to come on Monday, I said they shouldn't get tired for nothing.
There is no need for this attitude.
They are still walking in Sweden.
This and these marches continue.
Together with all their rags, They are on the road, planning
to form along our borders.
We have
already completed a significant part of the security zones we have opened,
and we are determined to
implement them as soon as possible in our work on the remaining parts,
especially our interlocutors in the region, we are trying to make the
necessary reconciliations
as soon as possible, and hopefully we are trying to make the regions in between safe as soon as possible.
I call out to
you allies in